hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the extra con Open
tournament being played in Elsinore
Denmark it's a game from round three and
although a lot of you have requested
that I didn't really have time to cover
it since I was covering the defeated
Grand Prix so it's why Sharlee versus
Samuel 7 by Charlize pregnant us older
sister and probably R stands for Raj
Babu the same as in pregnant Honda but
you know don't quote me on that
similar Savion very strong American
Grandmaster he's irate at some 300
points higher than white rally and he is
up to date I believe the youngest
American Grandmaster ever gained the
title at the age of 13 years and I
believe 7 months or something like that
but a very interesting matchup and well
without further ado let's just enjoy the
game why Charlie opens with E 4 with E 5
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and membership
to b5 so the rule opus is on the board
and here we have G 6 7 goes for the old
Chinese defense we have C 3 a sex
pushing the better back butter play for
and now Bishop to g7 fianchetto in the
dark square Bishop and d4 with ecad
force on B for C captures and now b5 and
here Bishop - C - Bishop to b3 also
playable depends on on what you want to
play so Bishop to see - and now b6 and
already if I Charlie grabs some space in
the central with d5 and here a 7 has to
decide what to do
he went Knight to a5 if you go Knight to
e5 it's not really all that great for
example there is one game in 1981 vasily
smyslov played 95 against Garry Kasparov
and Kasparov was able to win a very nice
game some like Knight captures pawn
captures and a4 Kasparov had a very nice
position after that so after that game I
don't think 90 if I was ever played
again we have night - a 5x7
castles bye-bye charlie and now Knight
to c4 continuing in the same fashion as
a Caruana
versus mamedyarov in the 2018 11 rapid
tournament it's the grand Chester's your
next move and there
we have Knight to c3 and here Knight to
f6 by seven in the game we already
mentioned Khurana versus mama Daryl my
madera played nice the East seven and he
was able to win the game but nice to f6
is played here and this is not a new
move so hard to say if seven knows about
the game Khurana versus Mahmud Arif
probably my guess is he doesn't as
Knight to f6 is not an improvement on
Mohammed arrows 97 but it was a rapid
game so who would who know that game and
not Knights to d4 Knight to c6 a very
nice square for the knight and probably
maybe one of the reasons why Mamedov
plays the night on e7 instead of on f6
but okay with castles here and now
Knight to c6 isn't a threat I mean you
could play it but then the Queen just
moves to e8 so this is more of a that
you know scenario where the threat is
stronger than the execution you know you
don't play it you just have the option
of playing it whenever you want and
black will have to calculate it every
move hit daddy plays so here b3 kicking
the night away from this very nice
square Knights to b6 and now a four so
of course you want to play a capture
some b5 as black will not be able to
recapture the rooks are not connected so
be captures on a4 with B captures an a4
and now a5 not allowing White's to push
a5 and now you want to get this rook
away from this nasty diagonal so roof
could be one also grabbing an open file
for your rook Bishop to d7 and now h3
just taking away the g4 square also some
pushing of the pawns might happen in the
future some f/4g for action
we have rook to e8 and now finally
Knight to c6 and here you could capture
if you capture what gets a very nice
pawn here you will be able to get your
knight over to d5 and then you will
either have a monster night or black
will have to capture it and then you
will promote at this point to defend the
c6 pawn all in all it will just be a
very tough position to play with black
so Queen to c8 7 doesn't capture the
night and now Queen to d3 we have Queen
- b7 now threatening to capture as the
Queen will be able to recapture the pawn
but Knight just goes back to d4 will
group the e7 7 now prepares the double
rook
and the e-file and now Bishop to g5 we
have h6 of course you don't want to
allow this Bishop to remain here and now
you can either move the bishop but then
after rook gets here it will be somewhat
difficult to defend your e4 pawn so here
by Sharlee trades with Bishop captures
on f6 Bishop captures on f6 and now f4
so grabbing even more space and now
Queen to a6 if you if you're not careful
if you play something f5 is coming and
white will start a very nice attack so
here are seven wants the trade Queen's
but of course a general principle in
chess will tell you that if you control
more space on the board then you do not
want to trade pieces especially not
Queens so Knight blocks with Knights the
b5 and now rook the d8 probably not rook
to e8 because you want to play something
like c6 or c5 you don't want this point
to remain a weakness here and c7 and you
want it to to just you know after the
pawn is traded and this position opens
up you don't want this point to remain a
target so probably that's why I wrote
the d8 and also you do not want to
capture anything on c7 because after the
Queen trade just rook c8 and you haven't
really accomplished anything
so Queen to g3 by Charlene our shifts
the attention over to the Kings side and
f5 is the plan you wanna bust open the
Kings side first Knights the c4 the idea
is Knights the d2 with an attack against
both groups so here you will win
material and although you can play
something like a rock f2 to block this
if I Charlie goes for a very nice each
five idea so what do you play here if
you capture it
the point is not to recapture but then
you push f5 and after g5 94 so you just
created a nice efore output for your
knight and here it would just be very
hard to play this for black your well
once the Queen is somehow overloaded you
can either capture the bishop or if you
move the bishop you can push f6 h 4 is
coming it's just a hard position to hold
so after E 5 we have Bishop to g7 by 7
but it doesn't help him all that much of
a shot it continues with a 6 so what do
you play here if you capture then Bishop
captures on g6 as possible
something you don't want to do here he
finds a clever defense Quinta be six
check with King 2h2 and now tonight the
ìiî attacking the rook on f1 but also
the undefended Bishop on c2 so what do
you play here if you capture on d7 than
just Knight captures and c2 it's not a
problem
one thing you could play his pawn
captures on f7 and after rook captures
just Bishop captures in g6 but the idea
involves a well in exchange sacrifice 0
and F 1 and F 2 F 6 you continue playing
this game where you are better but
probably if I surely did not want to you
know over push it against against 300
euro higher rated Grandmaster so she
found a different plan Queen to h4 now
just pressuring the rook here we have
rug DT 8 and now we have well it's a
very hard decision because here you can
just capture the bishop it comes with an
attack on the rook so it's a free piece
and after rook captures you your rook
and the bishop are under attack but you
just play rook back to c2 and black
doesn't really have any more threats
your upper piece and there really is no
compensation here so very interesting
why 7 would would play this but it's
even more interesting that by Charlotte
he doesn't go for material she continues
attacking f5 and here again what do you
play here here Knight captures on f1 was
played of course you just grab material
with wit check so it makes sense
rook captures on f1 and now Bishop
captures on b5 with Knight captures on
b5 and now again you could try something
like G captures Bishop captures and then
King - h8 getting your King away from
this check
probably or your best course of action
but here a 7 tried Bishop to e5 check
first with King - h1 and now f6 just
cementing that Bishop on e5 but now you
allow Queen captures on h6 and here was
sevens the last chance to really get
back into the game he should have played
the g5 and now you can try and get your
rooks into the game with rook to h7 even
threaten to somehow trap the Queen and
here white would probably have to go for
this
petrol there would be anything better
here not h6 obviously but h5 then king
repeats Queen gg6 chair but here seven
went for rook to g7 and now he allows
pawn captures on g6 which is quite
different than the one we've just shown
as here it's only wide it gets the play
on we have Queen to c5 attacking the
bishop but now Queen back to d2 in town
okay you're still up the exchange but
your rooks aren't doing anything and
there's a really no chance that they
will ever see any light of day as it's
very hard to get them into the game the
Queen guards the base of the pawn chain
here
Bishop does the same with the g6 pawn
black only has a dark square bishop so
you don't really have a way of attacking
any of the points because all of
virality spawns are on light squares so
perhaps you can maybe give up the
exchange back to grab some pawn here but
it's very hard to imagine here c6 is
probably the best you need to get rid of
this base of the pawn chain but here
Queen to c4 was played just attacking
the rook on f1 but here it doesn't work
now why Charlie just plays Queen to d3
and now if you trade after Bishop
captures on d3 you don't have any
counter play with black like I said the
bishop is useless
all of not just the pawns but all the
pieces and everything is on light
squares so you can move the ropes around
but not all that much you can try and
get this rook into the game but really
you can try rosy 8 to push the C pawn
now but now just 97 attack the rook rook
moves and now let's say a knight c6
still you will not be able to re-enter
the game with the rook the beat and B
Square is covered so this is pointless
to play with black so after Queen d3 of
course a7 declined we have Queen to h4
and now Knight to a3 preparing Knight to
c4 to go after the a5 pawn
so just watch Allah's plan is to create
a nice pass pawn on the Queen side with
f5 buy black and now not even capturing
the point you don't want to give black
and it can't play nice to see for
continuing with the plan with Bishop to
f6 and now Queen captures on f5 just
grabbing a nice clean pawn and okay
black now gets an open file for his rook
but it doesn't help him all that much
win back the e4 offering a queen trade
and you cannot trade here we have Queen
to g5 and now Knight captures an 85 so
grabbing yet another pawn what Charlie
now has six points two sevens to and
well you're your extra exchange doesn't
really do all that much so here we have
c5 and again not capturing even though
you could capture there is the danger of
losing the knight is non-existent
because if black captures you just play
rook captures on f6 rook captures and a
seven and there's no stopping the pawn
if you play something like 28 to prevent
then Bishop b3 wins on the spot King h8
Queen h4 check and it will be a nice
Queen h7 checkmate so after c5 vaishali
doesn't bother with this as there is a
simpler line Knight to c4 just go after
yet another pawn with Bishop to e7
defending and now rook to f7 just you
know a nice bone in blacks throat we
have looked back to b8 now claiming the
open B file but Queen to f3
now the threat is rook captures and g7
followed by Queen to f7 we have Queen to
c1 check King to h2 and now can you
capture the bishop no you can't we
already said that if you capture this
line follows rook captures King captures
and Queen f7 check and now you will pick
up all the material while delivering
check King h6 Queen h7 check when g5
King g5 and now you will pick up the
bishop with check and after black moves
then you go either Queen captures
wouldn't attack on the rogue but even
better Knight captures here and well
there are just too many passed pawns
if rogue be too threatening check not a
problem you'll just get your Queen into
in there a knight of seven check in
before you're gonna go Queen to h4
checking e3 Queen g3 check the g2 pawn
is defended and now you just push any of
the points and win the game easy
so after King to h2 we have looked back
to f8 but it's you know not a problem
just 93 the bishop is now defended the
white keeps all all the threats on the
board we have Queen to be 2 and now
Knight to g4 going for Knight to h6
check fall by Queen to h5 so here black
has to do something
rook G captures on f7 was played we have
he captures on f7 which
King 2h8 and now the you know the clean
finisher Queen to III and now this Redis
Queen h6 mate or if you block that then
you just lose material so 7 had to
defend mate he played Queen to g7 but
now just Queen captures on e7
and it was in this position that Samuel
7 resigned the game and a wonderful
victory for for progress sister by
Charlotte there is no defense against
Queen to h4 whatever black plays Queen
to h4 ends the game you will have to
give up the Queen and then it's just
mate
so really a beautiful if dare I say
karpova in victory as this game was all
about grabbing more space and really
just out playing you know 300 yo
higher-rated
grandmaster it was I mean this was just
insane so really a spectacular game I do
hope you enjoyed it I sure have and this
is not the only game of I Charlie won
against the Grandmaster in this
tournament so if you enjoyed this maybe
you would like to see another one you
know do do share in the comments if you
if you would this is a round six has
already been played and after six rounds
of I Charlie is on five out of six which
is just insane and pregnant and also is
playing in this tournament he's on five
and a half out of six sharing first
place really you know just a nice
brother-sister duo action you know here
really just destroying everyone but yeah
I once again I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Oscar Cabrera for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon
checking up on your suggestions such as
this one and we are about to continue
the Capablanca saga thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day